ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING
IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE
CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA BARRICADE
HAND BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BRIAN
BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DAILY DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY. GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY LACKEY LOUIS LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI THIS AREA WHEN WILL
DONALD PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS
CORK CORK SILVA RAMOS RAY IS
LOOSE REBAJAS ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SAY ARTURO SMITH STONE TAKING
REMOTE AREAS VIA FOOD WERE
VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WEBER WICKS
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
THAT OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. THE DAYS PRAYER
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR KHAN. YES
SIR. IN THE NAME OF GOD. THE
MOST GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL
BOGART OF POWER AND MERCY
DELIVER YOUR PEOPLE FROM EVERY
EVIL LET NOTHING HARM THE
DESTINY OF THIS NATION GIVE US
THE FREEDOM OF SPIRIT AND THE
HEALTH OF MIND AND BODY TO
ACCOMPLISH THE WORK YOU SET
BEFORE US MAY NOTHING PREVENT
US FOR MAKING RIGHT JUDGMENTS
AND PLACING OUR TRUST IN YOU
FOUNDED ON TRUTH BUILT ON
JUSTICE AND ANIMATED BY LOVE
MAJOR'S GOVERNMENT SERVE YOUR
PEOPLE YOU ARE THE LORD GOD
LIVING NOW AND FOREVER I MEAN.
THANK YOU MA'AM YES SIR YES OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
ONE PLEASE JOIN ME FOR THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE. TO THE FLAG ESSAYS.
ZERO SAN INDIVISIBLE WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY GERMAN
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY JUNE TWENTY
FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
ASSEMBLY REDDIT NINETY M. THE
AUDIBLE REBEKAH POWER QUE
HANNAH SYSTEM SPEAKER PRO
TEMPORE USE IN THE PRESIDING
CHIEF CLERK SU PROGRAMA DESTE
READING FOR DAVID ONLY READING
WILL CALL THE ROLL IS CALLED
STIRRED SHALL MOOSE AND MISTER
FLORES SECONDS. THAT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S
ABSENCES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. AND
MR CHOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS BURKE AND WEBER
TO HAVE GUESTS SEATED AT THEIR
DESKS. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
RADIOS KALRA IRWIN BURKE AND
LOSE WITH US TO SPEAK ON
INDETERMINATE MEMORY TODAY.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER FINALLY AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR'S
PLEASE REMOVE THE FOLLOWING
BILLS FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ITEMS SEVENTY FIVE SB
TWO THIRTY ONE MCGUIRE ITEM
SEVENTY EIGHT SB FOUR HUNDRED
JONES AND ITEM EIGHTY SIX SB
SEVEN FIFTY THREE ROTH. THE
CLERK WILL KNOW THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
CONCURRENCE ITEMS. WE HAVE
CONCURRENCE ITEMS TO TAKE UP.
IN FILE ORDER FILE ORDER NUMBER
ONE. THIS IS A B. EIGHT FIVE
FIVE BY MISTER RAMOS IN THE
CARBURETOR THE BILL EIGHT FIFTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS
AND OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
COURTS MR RAMA FEMALE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB EIGHT FIVE
FIVE IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
FROM THE SENATE FLOOR ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT FIVE FIVE ALLOWS FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN HISTORY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. FOR A
BRANCH OF THE GOVERNMENT OF THE
STATE COURTS TO HONOR
CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN DAY
AS A PAID HOLIDAY. I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
ROSS SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM WELL OVER
THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS AT ABOUT. YEAH. OKAY ALL
MEMBERS OUT OF.
WELL CLOSER
TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY FOUR NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO. AB SEVENTY FOUR
DOCTOR QUIRK FROM MS POWER K.
HANDS DESK COOKERY ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK AND
ACTIVITY IN THE TRANSPORTATION
DR COURT BAKER AND MEMBERS A.
B. SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR IS A
DISTRICT BILL THAT IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE WITH TECHNICAL IN
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS. I ASK
THE ARRIVAL TO CONFIRM TO
CONCUR WITH SENATE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DR WORK
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM CLICK LIBERAL ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. DESERT ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
TUCKWELL. THOSE ARE ALL TIED
OUT I FIFTY THREE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE.
BY MS RIVAS CORKERY. ASSEMBLY
BILL FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE OF US AND
OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTIONS MYSTERY THAT'S GOOD
MORNING MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
AB FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE IS BACK
ON CONCURRENCE THE EARLIER
VERSION OF AB FOURTEEN NINETY
FIVE WILL ENSURE CALIFORNIA
LAW. IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
SEVENTEENTH AMENDMENT OF THE TO
THE U. S. CONSTITUTION BY
PROVIDING FOR AN ELECTION TO BE
HELD TO FILL A VACANCY IN
CALIFORNIA'S REPRESENTATION. IN
THE U. S. SENATE EVEN IF THE
VACANCY OCCURS DURING THE LAST
TWO YEARS OF THE U. S. SENATE
TERM R. L. A. COUNTY IS
CURRENTLY PILOTING A PER
PROJECT USING AN ALTERNATE.
BALLOT ORDER WERE LOCAL OFFICES
APPEAR ON THE BALLOT BEFORE
STATE AND FEDERAL OFFICES. IT'S
UNCLEAR HOW THIS WOULD IMPACT
PARTICIPATION WHEN A SPECIAL
VACANCY AND REELECTION WOULD
APPEAR ON THE SAME BALLOT IN
DIFFERENT LOCATIONS. AB
FOURTEEN NINETY FIVE WILL
ENSURE THAT WHEN A SPECIAL
VACANCY ELECTION AND A REGULAR
ELECTION. FOR THE SAME
LEGISLATIVE OR CONGRESSIONAL
SEAT APPEAR ON THE SAME BALLOT.
VOTERS WILL BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY
AND UNDERSTAND THIS BY PLACING
THE TWO ELECTIONS AT THE FRONT
OF THE BALLOT WITH CLEARLY
MARKED HEADERS. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ISRAEL SAYING
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM LOCAL UP THERE ALL ALL
MEMBERS WHO IS OUT OF- ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. WHAT IS THAT ABOUT.
TUCKWELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
ICE FORTY FIVE MINUTES FOURTEEN
SENATE AMENDMENTS WORKING
CURTAIN. MEMBERS WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF ITEMS. ON SENATE
THIRD FOR AMENDMENT THESE ARE
AMENDMENTS OR WHEN WE TAKE IT
UP AMENDMENTS ON THE SENATE
THIRD READING FILE AMENDMENTS
ON SENATE THIRD. WE'RE GOING TO
AMENDMENTS ON THE SENATE THIRD
READING FILE MEMBERS. BEGINNING
WITH. FILE ITEM ELEVEN THIS IS
FILE ITEM ELEVEN ON SENATE
THIRD READING SB FOUR THIRTY
SIX FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS OPERATE WITHIN
MINUTES SENATE BILL FOR THIRTY
SIX WITH A MINUTES BY ASSEMBLY
BILL ASSEMBLY MEMBER BIGELOW
SHE BIGELOW ON THE MAMMOTHS
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY 2%
AMENDMENTS TO SP FOUR THREE SIX
THESE ARE CHATTERING OUT
AMENDMENTS TO AVOID CONFLICT
WITH EIGHTEEN TEN NINETY SIX.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I REQUEST HUMBLY AND I
VOTE FOR THE SENATOR. THANK YOU
MISS BIGELOW WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY
NAY THE I. SEVENTY MINUTES OUR
DOCTOR BILLS OUT TO PRINTED
BACK ON FILE. MEMBERS WE ARE
TAKING AMENDMENTS ON THE SENATE
THIRD READING FILE THIS IS FILE
ITEM FIFTEEN. SB THREE EIGHTY
THREE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENT CLERK WILL READ WITH
AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL THREE
EIGHTY THREE WITH A MEMBERS BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE MR STONE
ON THE MINUTES THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THIS BILL
BY SENATOR CORTESE IS ABOUT
DIVERSIONS AND WHAT THESE
AMENDMENTS ARE ARE ADDING SOME
MINOR EXPANSION TO THE
DIVERGENCE IN THE BILL AND I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MR STONE.
THAT OBJECTION MAY MAY MAY TAKE
A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY THE
EYES HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED THE BILL SOUTH PRINTER
BACK ON FILE AND THIS IS FILE
ITEM SIXTEEN. SB FIVE FORTY
FOUR FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CLERK READ WITH
AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL FIVE
FORTY FOUR WITH A MINUTES BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE MR STONE
AGAIN ON THE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOUMISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS
BILL IS ABOUT CANNABIS TESTING
IN THESE AMENDMENTS ALLOW
ADDITIONAL TYPES OF TESTING TO
BE ABLE TO BE UTILIZED I ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS MEMBERS WE MAY TAKE
A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED BILLS UP TO PRINTED
BACK ON FILE. THIS IS FILE ITEM
NINETEEN SB THREE FIFTEEN FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
COOKERY WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE
BILL THREE FIFTEEN WITH THE
MINUTES BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHAO. MISTER CHOW ON THE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AMENDMENTS TO SP THREE
FIFTEEN WHICH PROVIDES A TEN
YEAR SUNSET EXTENSION TO THE
REVOCABLE TRANSFER ON DEATH
DEEDS OR R. T. O. D. D. PILOT
PROGRAM AT THE END OF DROPS THE
CALIFORNIA LAW REVISION
COMMISSION'S RECOMMENDED
REFORMS. THE AMENDMENTS MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES TO THE R. T.
O. D. D. FREQUENTLY ASKED
QUESTIONS DOCUMENT AND PROVIDE
SPECIFICALLY ON THE CONDITIONS
THAT MUST BE SATISFIED IN ORDER
FOR AN R. T. O. D. D. TO BE
EFFECTIVE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR ARRIVAL THANK YOU MISTER
CHOW WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE
ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED
SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE IT THE
MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED THE BILLS
OUT TO PRINTER BACK ON FILE.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
AND FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO. WE
ARE GOING TO TAKE UP. FILE ITEM.
THIRTY THREE. SAYS FILE ITEM
THIRTY THREE. SB SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CLERK WILL READ WITH
AMENDED SENATE BILL SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROBERT
ROBERT RIVAS. MYSTERY THIS ON A
MOMENTS AND THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
IMMENSE TO SENATE BILL SEVEN TO
EIGHT BY SENATE MAJORITY LEADER
WHICH MAKES SOME TECHNICAL IN
CLARIFYING CHANGES RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL THANK YOU MISS REAVIS
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY THE EYES HAVE
IT MEMBERS ARE DOTTED THE
BILL'S OUT SPRINTED BACK ON
FILE. AND THIS IS FILE ITEM
THIRTY FIVE. SB EIGHT FOR THE
PURPOSE OF MANAGE CARBERY WITH
IMMENSE SENATE BILL EIGHT WITH
A MINUTES BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DALY MR DAILY ON THE MINUTES
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY'S AMENDMENTS ARE
MOSTLY CLARIFYING IN NATURE.
AND ARE THE RESULT OF
NEGOTIATIONS AMONG BUILDERS
TENANTS RIGHTS GROUPS AND
CITIES I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
DALY. WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE
ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED
SAY NAY THE I. SEVENTY MEMBERS
ARE DR BILLS OUT THE PRINTED
BACK ON FILE. THIS IS FILE ITEM.
THIRTY EIGHT. THIS IS FILE ITEM
THIRTY EIGHT SB THIRTY FIVE.
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
CLERK WILL READ WITH AMENDMENTS
SENATE BILL THIRTY FIVE WITH
THE MINUTES BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN MR BERMAN EMAIL BUT I
THE MENACE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR WRITES
RESENTMENTS THE SENATE BILL
THIRTY FIVE. THESE AMENDMENTS
WHICH WERE REQUESTED BY THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE ARE
INTENDED TO ASSIST WITH THE
ORDERLY IMPLEMENTATION OF
EXISTING LAW. FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO PRIMARY ELECTION I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. ON THE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MR BERMAN
AND MR FLOOR FOR WHAT PURPOSE-
WITH LOTS OF LOVE ON THE
AMENDMENTS WE WITHHOLD EMAILS
CONSENT. AND AS FOR ROLL CALL
VOTE MISTER FLORES ASKING FOR A
ROLL CALL VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS CLARK WELL OVER THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ON THE
AMENDMENTS ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL CULTURAL
TYLER IS FORTY SEVEN KNOWS
THIRTEEN THE MEMBERS ARE DOCTOR
BILLS OUT TO PRINCE AND BACK ON
FILE MEMBERS RUN A MOVE BACK IN
THE FILE TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM
TWENTY TWO THIS IS FILE ITEM
TWENTY TWO. SB FIFTY TWO FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
CORKERY WITHIN MINUTES SENATE
BILL FIFTY TWO WITH THE MINUTES
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER AG WE ARE
CURRY IS AGUIAR-CURRY ON THE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
AMENDMENTS TO SB FIFTY TWO BY
SENATOR DODD. THESE ARE DOUBLE
JOINTING AMENDMENTS WHICH WOULD
PREVENT POSSIBLE CHAPTER RING
WITH WITH OUT WITH A AB FORTINO
THREE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED THE BILL SET
UP TO PRINT AND RETURN TO THE
THIRD READING FILE OUR SYSTEM
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY ROOM.
THANK YOU MISS AGUIAR-CURRY C.
NOTIFICATION OF THESE
AMENDMENTS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE FOR ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE HI ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED
SAY NAY THE EYES HAVE IT THE
MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED BILLS OUT
THE PRINT BACK ON FILE. MEMBERS
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY ROLE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT. TWO. I AM
REFERRING SB THIRTY FIVE ON
BURKE TO THE ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS WE ARE
TAKING UP AMENDMENTS ON THE
SENATE THIRD READING FIVE. THIS
IS FILE ITEM FIFTY FOUR. F.
FIVE FIFTY FOUR SENATE BILL
SEVEN NINETY TWO FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS COURT
AGREED WITH THE MATTER SENATE
BILL SEVEN NINETY TWO WITH A
MEMBERS BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK. DR COURT ON THE IMMENSE
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
AMENDMENTS AT THE DESK FOR SB
SEVEN NINE TO. CLARIFY THE
DEFINITION OF A QUALIFIED SALE
TAKEN. THESE MEN WHICH WERE
DRAFTED AT THE SUGGESTION OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU THANK YOU DR WORK WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY THE EYES HAVE
IT THE MEMBERS ARE NOT THE
BILLS OUT TO PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE. OR AND FINALLY THIS IS
FILE ITEM FIFTY NINE SB FIVE
NINETY FOUR FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS AND THE CLERK WILL
READ WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE
BILL FIVE NINETY FOUR WITH THE
MINUTES BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN MR BERMAN ON MMS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR RICE PRESENT
AMENDMENTS THE SENATE BILL FIVE
NINETY FOUR. THESE AMENDMENTS
ADDRESS LOGISTICAL CHALLENGES
FOR THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
OFFICE WITH PREPARATIONS FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY TWO PRIMARY
ELECTION IN LIGHT OF THE DELAY
IN THE RELEASE OF CENSUS DATA
AND THE CORRESPONDING DELAY. IN
THE ADOPTION OF NEW DISTRICT
LINES I ASK THAT THE M. M. S.
B. ADOPTED IN THE BILL BE SENT
OUT TO PRINT. AND PLACE BACK ON
FILE THANK IS BERMAN WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY THE EYES HAVE
IT THE MEMBERS ARE DOCTOR BILLS
OUT TO PRINT TO BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOT GOING TO BE
MOVING BACK TO THE ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING FILE THIS IS
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. FILE
ITEMS FOUR THROUGH SIX PASS AND
RETAIN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER. SEVEN. THIS IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN. HR. SIXTY
SIX. H. R. SIXTY SIX AND THE
CLERK WILL READ HOUSE WAS
SOLUTION SIXTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KITA WEBER RELATIVE TO
WOMEN'S EQUALITY DAY DR WEBER
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT H. R. SIXTY SIX
WHICH COMMEMORATES THE PASSAGE
OF THE NINETEENTH AMENDMENT AND
DESIGNATES AUGUST TWENTY SIXTH
AS WOMEN'S EQUALITY DAY ON THIS
DAY WE RECOGNIZE THE PIONEERING
WOMEN WHO FOUGHT TIRELESSLY FOR
WOMEN TO OBTAIN THE RIGHT TO
VOTE AND COMMEMORATE THE NAME
OF THOSE WHO STOOD AT THE
FOREFRONT OF THIS HISTORICAL
MOVEMENT. SURGERY NO TRUTH
SUSAN B. ANTHONY AND ELIZABETH
STANTON HOWEVER NOT ALL WOMEN
WERE INCLUDED IN THIS VICTORY
IN FACT VOTING RIGHTS FOR WOMEN
OF COLOR DID NOT COME INTO THE
MID TWENTIETH CENTURY NATIVE
AMERICAN WOMEN IN NINETEEN
TWENTY FOUR CHINESE AMERICAN
WOMEN NINETEEN FORTY THREE.
JAPANESE AND OTHER ASIAN
AMERICAN WOMEN. NINETEEN FIFTY
TWO. AND IT WAS NOT INTO THE
PASSAGE OF THE VOTING RIGHTS
ACT IN NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE
FORTY FIVE YEARS AFTER THE
ENACTMENT OF THE NINETEENTH
AMENDMENT THAT BLACK WOMEN
COULD EXERCISE THIS RIGHT
WITHOUT RESTRICTIONS WOMEN'S
EQUALITY DAY ALSO ACKNOWLEDGES
THAT. EVEN NOW BARRIERS TO
WOMEN'S PARTICIPATION AND
EQUALITY IN ALL SPHERES OF
LIFE. AND SOCIETY STILL EXIST
ON MANY LEVELS FOR EXAMPLE. IN
CALIFORNIA'S THRIVING STEM
FIELD WOMEN ONLY MAKE UP 28% OF
THAT WORKFORCE IN PARTICULAR
ENGINEERING AND COMPUTER
SCIENCES TWO OF THE MOST
LUCRATIVE STEM FEELS REMAIN
HEAVILY MALE DOMINATED ONLY 21%
OF ENGINEERING MAJORS AND 19%
OF COMPUTER SCIENCE MAJORS ARE
WOMEN WOMEN ARE ALSO AND
REPRESENTED IN LEADERSHIP ROLES
IN MEDICINE WELL 30% OF FULL
TIME POSITIONS ARE WOMEN AND
50% OF MEDICAL SCHOOL STUDENTS
ARE WOMEN THERE IS A GREATER
DISPARITY AND DISCREPANCY AND
WOMEN IN LEADERSHIP ROLES SUCH
AS CHAIRS OF VARIOUS DIVISIONS
AND DEANS OF MEDICAL SCHOOLS
WHEN IT COMES TO EMPLOYMENT
WOMEN WHO POSSESS THE SAME
QUALIFICATIONS AS THEIR MALE
COUNTERPARTS EARN FAR LESS WHEN
ENTERING INTO SIMILAR
PROFESSIONS SPECIFICALLY WHITE
WOMEN EARN SEVENTY NINE CENTS
FOR EVERY DOLLAR A WHITE MALE
EARNS AND IT IS MORE EGREGIOUS
FOR WOMEN OF COLOR BLACK WOMEN
WITH THE SAME QUALIFICATIONS
EARNED SIXTY TWO CENTS FOR
EVERY DOLLAR A WHITE MALE
EARNS. AMERICAN INDIAN AND
ALASKA NATIVE EARNED FIFTY
SEVEN CENTS. AND LATINA WOMEN
EARNING FIFTY FOUR CENTS
INEQUALITIES FOR WOMEN OF COLOR
DURING THE PANDEMIC INFLUENCED
RECESSION HAVE BEEN EXACERBATED
WITH UNEMPLOYMENT AND
HOMELESSNESS DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTING WOMEN ACROSS ALL
SECTORS SO BY RECOGNIZING
WOMEN'S HE CALLED QUALITY DAY
WE ARE NOW DOING WOMEN ARE
STILL FIGHTING IN MANY WAYS TO
OBTAIN FULL EQUALITY IN SOCIETY
WOMEN EQUALITY DAY REMINDS US
THAT WE HAVE MUCH MORE WORK TO
DO TO PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF ALL
WOMEN REGARDLESS OF RACE AND
ECONOMIC STATUS SO AS WE
CELEBRATE THE NINETEENTH
AMENDMENT LETTER SIGNALING THAT
WE MUST TREAT THE INJUSTICES OF
SEXISM NOT AS AN ISSUE OF THE
PAST. BUT A CONTINUOUS MOVEMENT
TO CORRECT THE INJUSTICES IN
OUR COUNTRY'S PAST AND PRESENT
NEVERTHELESS SHE PERSISTED. AND
COLLEAGUES SO SHOULD WE- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND I'D LIKE TO OPEN THE
FIRST ROLE FOR COLLECTORS THANK
YOU THANK YOU DR WEBER MS
GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I REMEMBER
SOMEONE I THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO FOR BRINGING
THIS RESOLUTION BOARD AND FOR
HER GREAT WORK THIS MORNING ON
BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS I RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF. HR SIXTY SIX I TO
THEY WERE CELEBRATING THE ONE
HUNDRED FIRST YEAR THAT WOMEN
WERE GRANTED THE RIGHT TO VOTE
ACROSS THE NATION AND WE HAVE A
LOT TO CELEBRATE HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE CON THE END OF THE
MONTH WE'RE GONNA HAVE THIRTY
NINE WOMEN WHICH IS THE MOST OF
EVER HAD SERVING AT ANY POINT
IN THE STATE LEGISLATURE. AND
SO I WANT TO TAKE A SECOND TO
CELEBRATE THAT VICTORY I WANT
TO REMIND IS THAT WE'RE STILL
TWENTY ONE SHY OF PARITY ALONG
THE WAY AND SO WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH ALL OF YOUTO
MAKE SURE WE GET THAT PARITY
AND THAT THAT PARTY REFLECTS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
COVERS ALL APPRENTICE AND ENTER
SEXUALITIES ALONG THE WAY. THE
CAUCUS WAS FORMED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN BY NINE DEMOCRATS
AND SIX REPUBLICANS IF THE
PRESENCE OF WOMEN IN OUR STATE
LEGISLATURE GOES BACK TO
NINETEEN EIGHTEEN WHEN THE
FIRST FOUR WOMEN WERE ELECTED
TO THE STATE ASSEMBLY GRACE
DORIS AS THE ROAD TEN AND ESTEE
LAUDER. AND ELIZABETH USE AS WE
WILL FORTY STRIVE AS WE MOVE
FORWARD AND CONTINUE STRIVE IS
ESSENTIAL TO THE KNOWLEDGE THAT
WOMEN ARE VARYING CULTURES
SOCIOECONOMIC STATUS. AND THAT
THE BACKGROUNDS OF PARTICIPATE
IN THE FOUNDING AND BUILDING OF
OUR STATE AND OUR NATION IT'S
MY HOPE THAT WE WILL CONTINUE
TO PUSH THIS TOWARDS A MORE
REPRESENTATIVE GOVERNMENT. NOT
ONLY FOR US BUT FOR EVERY YOUNG
GIRL WHO IS SITTING BACK AND
WATCHING THESE MOMENTS UNFOLD.
HOPING TO ONE DAY CHANGE THE
WORLD. AND LET US REFLECT. WE
HAVE ALWAYS AND REMAIN AND WILL
CONTINUE TO PROTECT WOMEN'S
RIGHTS. LET'S CELEBRATE THIS
HISTORIC DAY IN A CONTINUE TO
DO THE GOOD WORK THAT STILL
NEEDS TO BE DONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISS GARCIA SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION DR WEBER'S ASSET
THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE HOUSE RESOLUTION
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL
NUMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON H. R. SIXTY SIX.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. CLICK
WELL CLOSER ALL THERE ARE SIXTY
NINE CO AUTHORS ADDED AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON HOUSE RESOLUTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY THE EYES HAVE
IT THE HOUSE RESOLUTION. IS
ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING
TO BE TAKING UP SELECT ITEMS ON
SENATE THIRD READING THIS IS
THE SENATE THIRD READING FILE.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM. FOURTEEN. SENATE BILL
THREE THIRTY ONE. QUICKLY
SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY ONE BY
CENTER LEYVA AND ACALYPTRIS OF
ELECTIONS MS REYES THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SENATE BILL
THREE THIRTY ONE ALSO KNOWN AS
A SILENCED NO MORE ACT EXPANDS
THE PROHIBITION ON NON
DISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS NDAS TO
NOW COVER SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS
INVOLVING ALL FORMS OF
HARASSMENT OR DISCRIMINATION.
THIS BILL ALSO EXPANDS THE
PROHIBITION ON OVERLY BROAD
CONFIDENTIALITY AND NON
DISPARAGEMENT CLAUSES IN
EMPLOYMENT AGREEMENTS TO COVER
WORKERS WHO ARE REQUIRED TO
SIGN THESE TYPES OF CLAUSES AS
PART OF A SEVERANCE AGREEMENT
RECENT AMENDMENTS CLARIFY THAT
THIS BILL IS NOT RETROACTIVE
AND THE SEVERANCE AMOUNT MAY BE
KEPT CONFIDENTIAL AND HOUSE
REMOVE THE OPPOSITION OF THE
CHAMBER AND OTHERS. IT'S
UNACCEPTABLE FOR AN EMPLOYER TO
TRY TO SILENCE A WORKER BECAUSE
THEY ARE VICTIMS OF ANY TYPE OF
HARASSMENT OR DISCRIMINATION
THE SILENCE NO MORE ACT WILL
EMPOWER SURVIVORS TO SPEAK OUT
IF THEY SO WISH SO THE
PERPETRATORS CAN BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND WE CAN
HOPEFULLY PREVENT ABUSERS FROM
CONTINUING TO TORMENT AND ABUSE
OTHER WORKERS MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON SB THREE THIRTY ONE.
THANK YOU MISS REYES. C.
NOTIFICATION OR DEBATE ON THE
ADAM. CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
WHAT IS THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. WELL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY EIGHT
KNOWS TWELVE. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE ARE MOVING TO TAKE
A FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN. THIS IS
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN. SB SIX
FIFTY FIVE. COOKERY SENATE BILL
SIX FIFTY FIVE BY SOONER
BRADFORD AND ACTIVITY TO
INSURANCE MR DALY THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THIS BILL
WILL STRENGTHEN EQUITY
DIVERSITY AND TRANSPARENCY IN
OUR STATE'S INSURANCE INDUSTRY
IT A STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND NO OPPOSITION I REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU MISS
DALY CITY NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. CLARK WELL OVER THERE
ALL. WHO DECIDED THAT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF- ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. WHAT IS THAT
ABOUT. CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL
THE TIME BUT I SIXTY ONE NO
ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
IN
MEMBERS WE WILL NOW TAKE A FILE
ITEM THIRTY SIX. SB NINE THIS
IS FILE ITEM THIRTY SIX SB
NINE. CORPORATION SENATE BILL
NINE BUYS ATKINS AND OTHERS AN
APPLICANT'S LAND USE MYSTERY
THAT'S YOU MAY OPEN WELL THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS WHAT
THEY GET READY FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. PRESENT US
SENATE BILL NINE HERE THIS
MORNING ON BEHALF OF SENATE-
PROTON TONI ATKINS THIS IS A
MOMENT THAT THAT SOME SO MANY
OF US WHO ARE WORKING ON WAYS
TO ADDRESS OUR STATE'S HOUSING
CRISIS- HAVE BEEN WAITING FOR.
WE'VE BEEN ON A MULTI YEAR
QUEST FOR SOLUTIONS. AND THIS
MORNING WE HAVE ONE OF THOSE
SOLUTIONS RIGHT HERE FOR OUR-
OF OUR VOTE IN A CONSIDERATION
AND IT'S NOT A PERFECT BAYLOR A
SOLUTION BUT IT IS A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION THAT WILL
BEGIN TO HAVE A POSITIVE IMPACT
ARE CRIPPLING HOUSING CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA SB NINE THE
CALIFORNIA HOME ACT TO PROVIDE
OPTIONS FOR HOMEOWNERS AND
SINGLE FAMILY ZONES IT DOES
THIS BY STREAMLINING THE
PROCESS TO ALLOW FOR THE
CREATION OF A DUPLEX. OR
PROVIDING THEM THE OPTION TO
SUBDIVIDE IN EXISTING LAW TO
CREATE MORE HOUSING MODELED
AFTER EXISTING EXISTING
CALIFORNIA EIGHTY YOU LAW.
WHICH ALLOWS FOR AT LEAST THREE
UNITS PER LOT SENATE BILL NINE
ALLOWS FOR UP TO FOUR UNITS PER
LOT. AND FOR MANY OF YOU THIS
THIS THIS THIS BILL WILL LOOK
VERY SIMILAR TO A BILL THAT-
MATTER PRO TEM AUTHORED LAST
SESSION ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
TWENTY. WHICH PASSED OFF THIS
FLOOR WITH SOME BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND AFTER LISTENING TO
FEEDBACK FROM HOMEOWNERS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS LAST YEAR'S SENATE
BILL ELEVEN TWENTY WAS
SUBSTANTIALLY IMPROVED UPON TO
BECOME THIS YEAR'S SENATE BILL
NINE. THE FIRST SENATE BILL
NINE ESTABLISHES A SPECIFIC
LIST OF QUALIFICATIONS THAT
MUST BE MET TO PROTECT EXISTING
TENANTS HISTORIC DISTRICTS BY
MIDDLE QUALITY IN COASTAL
REQUIREMENTS SECOND THE BILL
NOW IT BETTER PROTECTS
NEIGHBORHOODS. ASIAN BY MAKING
IT A STATE WIDE REQUIREMENT TO
SURE THAT HOMEOWNERS WILL
BENEFIT FROM THESE NEW HOUSING
OPTIONS NOT CORPORATE INVESTORS
THIRD SENATE BILL NINE NOW
AUTHORIZES A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
TO DENY A PROPOSED HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT OR A LOT SPLIT IF A
BUILDING OFFICIAL MAKES A
FINDING THAT THERE IS AN
ADVERSE IMPACT ON PUBLIC HEALTH
PUBLIC SAFETY WHAT'S THE
PHYSICAL ENVIRONMENT IF THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CAN DOCUMENT
THIS ADVERSE IMPACT FOR
PROPOSED PROJECTS PERHAPS EIGHT
SPECIFIC FIRE HAZARD THEY HAVE
THE DISCRETION TO DENY THAT
PROPOSED PROJECT IF THERE IS NO
WAY TO MITIGATE THE HAZARD OR
ADVERSE IMPACT IN THIS
PARTICULAR MOMENT IS IMPORTANT
AS WE ALL KNOW IT'S IMPORTANT
TO ENSURE THAT SENATE BILL NINE
STRIKES AN APPROPRIATE BALANCE
BETWEEN RESPECTING LOCAL
CONTROL. AND CREATING THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR MORE HOUSING
OPTIONS IN PARTICULAR MORE
OPTIONS FOR FAMILIES TO BUILD
MULTI GENERATIONAL HOUSING TO
BUILD MULTI GENERATIONAL ASSETS.
INTERGENERATIONAL WEALTH IS A
CURRENCY THAT WE KNOW IS
CRUCIAL CRUCIAL TO COUNTERING
INEQUITY CREATING SOCIAL
MOBILITY ESPECIALLY ESPECIALLY
IN NEIGHBORHOODS WERE OUTDATED
ZONING LAWS HAVE CREATED
BARRIERS TO AFFORDABLE HOME
OWNERSHIP AND HAVE LED TO
OVERCROWDING LET'S BE FRANK
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CRISIS IS
A CRISIS SO LARGE THAT THERE IS
NO ONE SINGLE SOLUTION NO BILL
IS NO BILL WILL BE A SILVER
BULLET. BUT THERE ARE BILLS
THEIR BILLS THAT WILL HELP MOVE
THE NEEDLE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION THERE ARE BILLS THAT
OFFER SOLUTIONS. A PATH FORWARD.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE BILLS THE
ROLE OF GOVERNMENT IS TO
INTERVENE TO INTERVENE WHEN
THERE IS A CRISIS. TO ENSURE
THAT EVERYONE'S VOICES ARE
HEARD TO WORK COLLABORATIVELY
ON A COMPROMISE AND ULTIMATELY
TO MAKE PROGRESS ON ISSUES AND
ESPECIALLY ON ISSUES OF CRISIS
THE BOTTOM LINE SENATE BILL
NINE WILL PROVIDE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MORE WORKING
FAMILIES TO ACHIEVE THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM AND MAKES THE
PATH TO HOME OWNERSHIP IN OUR
STATE A MORE INCLUSIVE ONE. FOR
ALL THESE REASONS RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I VOTE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER THANK YOU MISS
REAVIS AND MISTER HOLDEN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE.
THIS BILL ALLOWS GRADUAL
DENSITY INCREASES IN ALREADY
DEVELOPED NEIGHBORHOODS BUT
EXAMS THE STORE DISTRICTS. THIS
WILL KEEP PEOPLE CLOSE TO JOB
CENTERS AND TRANSIT DECREASE
COMMUTE TIMES AND SLOW DOWN
DEVELOPMENT INTO WILDLIFE
WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE I WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THAT SB NINE DOES
NOT ALLOW SIX UNITS ON A SINGLE
LOT THE CAMPUS FOR UNITS. NOT
FOR UNITS PLUS EIGHTY USE FOR
UNITS TOTAL INCLUDING A TO USE
SOME OF MY CONSTITUENTS ARE
ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT DEVELOPERS
COMING IN TO MAKE A QUICK BUCK
AND CHANGING THE CHARACTER OF
THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD CITIES WILL
HAVE LOCAL CONTROL IN THE
AUTHORITY TO DENY A PROPOSED
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT AT THE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT POSES A
RISK TO PUBLIC HEALTH. OR
SAFETY RECENT AMENDMENTS ALSO
REQUIRE THAT THE OWNER OF THE
RITUAL LOT SIGN AN AFFIDAVIT
STATING THAT THEY WILL LIVE ON
ONE OF THE LOTS. AFTER THE LOT
SPLIT FOR AT LEAST THREE YEARS
ALSO NOTHING IN THIS BILL
PRECLUDES LOCAL GOVERNMENT FROM
CHARGING IMPACT FEES FOR NEW
CONSTRUCTION AS A RESULT OF A
PROJECT UNDER SB NINE TO
DECREASED IMPACT ON
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THESE
REASONS I SUPPORT SB. NINE.
TECHNISCHE HOLDEN MR SAY ARE
TELL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER ACTUALLY I
MUST ARISE IN OPPOSITION OF SB
NINE. SB NINE CAN BE CALLED
COMMUNITY PLANNING CHAOS
BECAUSE WHAT IT DOES IS
RETROACTIVELY FOR COMMUNITIES
LIKE THE ONES I REPRESENT THAT
ARE LESS THAN THIRTY YEARS OLD
WHAT IT DOES IS IT IT MAKES ALL
OF THE PLANNING ALL THE MASTER
PLANNING ALL THE SEAT WAS.
ENVIRONMENTAL APPROVALS THAT
WENT INTO MAKING THOSE
COMMUNITIES- ENABLING THEM TO
HAVE THE DEVELOPMENT THEY HAVE
TODAY. IT LAYS TO WASTE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT HAVE
BEEN SPENT DOING THAT. IT ALSO
WILL AFFECT FUTURE DEVELOPMENT
AS THEY HAVE TO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT. THE DOUBLING OF THE
POPULATION THAT IS JUST THE
POTENTIAL FOR HAVING TO. TWO
HOUSES ON ONE LOT FOR ALL OF
THESE SINGLE FAMILY
DEVELOPMENT. WHICH MEANS IT
WILL IMPACT THE APPROVALS OF
FUTURE HIGH DENSITY PROJECTS.
FUTURE COMMERCIAL PROJECT IT
LAYS TO WASTE OUR EFFORTS TO
HAVE APPROVED TO TRAFFIC
CIRCULATION PLANS AIR QUALITY
PLAN APPROVALS WATER AND SEWER
INFRASTRUCTURE PARKING AN
EMERGENCY VEHICLE ACCESS IN
OTHER DEVELOPMENTS AS I'VE
STATED BEFORE. THIS TAKES MANY
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE LESS THAN
THIRTY YEARS OLD OUT OF
COMPLIANCE WITH THE VERY
REGULATIONS THAT WE CREATED
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE WE'RE
JUST GONNA PUSH THAT ASIDE PUSH
AWAY THOSE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
THAT WE HAVE FORCE THOSE
COMMUNITIES TO SPAN INSTEAD OF
BUILDING BUILDING OUT THEIR
STREETS AND BUILDING OUT THESE
OTHER THINGS. THEY FORCED THEM
TO SPEND A MONTH PLANS THAT WE
CREATED WE'RE GONNA THROW THOSE
ASIDE AND TELL THESE
COMMUNITIES YOU HAVE TO CHANGE
THE CHARACTER OF YOUR
COMMUNITY. SO THAT WE CAN SOLVE
A PROBLEM. THAT'S NOT GOING TO
BE SOLVED BY THIS WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS THE UNDERLYING PROBLEM
OF WHY WE CAN'T BUILD HOUSES IN
CALIFORNIA. WHY WE CAN'T BRING
IN BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA AND
THAT THOSE UNDERLYING CAUSES
HAVE TO DO WITH OUR
REQUIREMENTS OUR REGULATIONS IF
WE'RE NOT GOING TO ADDRESS THAT
THINGS LIKE THIS ARE JUST
BANDAIDS THAT WON'T WORK SO FOR
THOSE REASONS. I HAVE TO I HAVE
TO ASK FOR YOU KNOW VOTE ON SB
NINE THANK YOU DAVIS AIRTEL
MISTER MATHIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AYE I RISE TO
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS
MEASURE. AND I WILL TELL YOU
WHY BECAUSE WE WE'VE HEARD BOTH
SIDES OF THIS ALREADY ON THIS
DEBATE THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS
THERE'S A LOT OF CONCERNS ABOUT
DEVELOPERS ARE GONNA COME IN
THEY'RE GOING TO TURN UP MY
NEIGHBORHOOD THINGS ARE GONNA
CHANGE WE'VE ALREADY DONE THE
IMPACTS OF THE ON THE
ENVIRONMENT WE'VE DONE THIS. AS
WE'VE ALSO ALREADY HEARD
THERE'VE BEEN AMENDMENTS ON
THIS LEGISLATION TO ENSURE THAT
THE CITY'S CAN DENY THE ABILITY
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
PROJECT BASED ON THOSE SAME
CONCERNS THERE'VE BEEN
MITIGATION ASPECTS WORKED INTO
THIS IF YOU HAVE AN H. AWAY
THIS ISN'T FOR YOU THIS ISN'T
BIG GUYS COMING IN AND TEARING
UP YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD NOW I KNOW
SOME PEOPLE MIGHT FEEL THAT WAY
I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF CONCERN
AND THERE'S FRANKLY WAY TOO
MUCH MISCOMMUNICATION OUT THERE
I TALKED TO MY LOCALS I GOT
SOME LOCALS ALIKE AND I GOT
SOME LOCALS WHO DON'T. BECAUSE
OF THE MISCOMMUNICATION THAT'S
HAPPENING I THINK THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE SALINAS
VALLEY TOUCHED ON SOME REALLY
GOOD POINTS ABOUT THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE MITIGATIONS
PUT INTO THIS. MY COLLEAGUE
FROM LA TOUCHED ON A GREAT
POINT THIS IS FOR LOTS YOU HAVE
TO STAY THERE FOR THREE YEARS.
THIS IS BASED TO HELP. LOW
INCOME PEOPLE LIKE IN MY AREA
WHO HAVE THESE OLD FAMILY LOSS
I HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO THIS
THINK SO YOU KNOW WHAT I WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE CREATE THAT
GENERATIONAL WEALTH I WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO BUILD SOME. EQUITY FOR
THE FAMILY AND BE ABLE TO DO
THAT THIS ISN'T. THE PEOPLE
GOING TO GO IN TO YOUR BIG
SUBDIVISION THAT THE YOU'VE
BUILDING FOR ALL THIS OTHER
STUFF IF YOU'RE IN AN AREA
THAT'S GROWING. THAT'S BUILDING
UP THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S NOT
REALLY EVEN GOING TO AFFECT YOU
THIS IS FOR OUR POPULATIONS
WORDS SO DANCE. AND THERE'S NOT
GROWTH GOING ON WE'LL HAVE A
FEW OF THOSE BLOTTO YOU MEMBERS
MIGHT BE BIGGEST FRUSTRATION
WITH THIS BILL IS THE DAM
MISCOMMUNICATION ON BECAUSE
I'VE HEARD ALL THE ARGUMENTS
I'VE LOOKED AT IT I'VE READ IT
I'VE TALKED TO THE AUTHOR OF
TALK TO PEOPLE IN OPPOSITION OF
TALKED EVERYBODY AT HOME. AND
AGAIN SOME PEOPLE LIKE IT SOME
PEOPLE DON'T IF YOU DON'T MAYBE
IT'S OKAY VOTE NO I GET IT WE
ALL HAVE DIFFERENT DISTRICTS
BERNIE MY DISTRICT MY LOCAL
THAT I'VE TALKED TO. EVEN
THOUGH IT'S A MIXED BAG THERE
ARE THE MITIGATION STEPS THAT
WILL HELP YOUR CITY CAN STILL
DENY THIS YOU STILL HAVE SOME
OF THAT LOCAL CONTROL. THINK
ABOUT A MEMBERS. THIS CREATES
GENERATIONAL EQUITY THIS
CREATES GENERATIONAL GROWTH. I
ASK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON
THIS THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS
MISSED WICKS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS- MY COLLEAGUES FROM
SALINAS AND PASADENA HAVE
ARTICULATED MANY OF THE REASONS
WHY I'M A PROUD SUPPORTER OF
THIS BILL AND I WILL SAY IT'S
NOT OFTEN ME AND MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE CELL ACTUALLY AGREE ON
SOMETHING SO I STAND WITH HIM
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AS
WELL. AND THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
MISTRUTHS ABOUT THIS BILL THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN ARTICULATED
MANY SAY I SAT IN A HOUSING
COMMITTEE AND HEARD A LOT OF
THIS INFORMATION COMING THROUGH
HOUSING COMMITTEE AND THERE'S A
LOT OF INACCURACIES BY THE
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. PEOPLE
HAVE SAID THIS WILL RESULT IN
SIX EIGHT TEN UNITS PER LOT AND
THAT IS SIMPLY NOT TRUE AS
YOU'VE HEARD FOR MAXIMUM
INCLUDING EIGHTY USE PEOPLE SAY
THIS WILL LEAD TO WIDESPREAD
DEVELOPMENT BY CORPORATE
LANDLORDS NOT TRUE RECENT
AMENDMENTS REQUIRE THAT. THE
SPLIT LOTS BE OWNEROCCUPIED
FOR THREE YEARS TO PROTECT
AGAINST THE SORT OF SPECULATION
AND DISPLACEMENT PEOPLE SAY
THAT THIS WILL OVERRIDE LOCAL
LAWS REGARDING DESIGN STANDARDS
ALSO NOT TRUE ANY LOCAL
ORDINANCE RELATED TO SET BACKS
HEIGHTS LANDSCAPING DESIGNER
OTHER RESTRICTIONS THAT APPLY
TO SINGLE FAMILY HOMES. WILL
STILL APPLY IN THIS BILL PEOPLE
SAY THAT THIS IS GOING TO
RESULT IN HIGH DENSITY
DEVELOPMENTS IN IN HIGH RISK
FIRE AREAS ALSO NOT TRUE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN STILL DENY
HOUSING PROJECTS AND HIGH FIRE
ZONES THIS IS SMART POLICY
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US ON THIS
FLOOR HAS THAT AT SOME POINT WE
HAVE TO BUILD MORE HOUSING. NO
ONE THINKS WE DON'T HAVE TO
BILL RIGHT NOW IS OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO ACTUALLY VOTE
FOR THAT TO VOTE FOR WHAT YOU
BELIEVE IN TO BUILD MORE%
HOUSING WE NEED MORE SOLUTIONS
IN THE STATE. RIGHT NOW IN TWO
THIRDS OF CALIFORNIA- MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING- MISSING MIDDLE
HOUSING IS ILLEGAL LET'S
LEGALIZE HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA
AND VOTE FOR SB NINE. THANK YOU
MS WICKS MEMBERS IF YOU'D LIKE
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE BAY
PLEASE RAISE YOUR MICROPHONES
AT THIS TIME. PLEASE RAISE YOUR
MICROPHONES AT THIS TIME. IF
YOU WANT TO PARTICIPATE IN
DEBATE MR GRAYSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL NINE
FIND OUT YOU'VE LIKELY HEARD
ALL ABOUT THE DETAILS OF THIS
BILL FROM BOTH SIDES HOW WE CAN
ONLY RESULT IN A MAXIMUM OF
FOUR UNITS ON A LOT THAT WAS
SPLIT HOW IT PROTECTS AGAINST
DISPLACEMENT AND SPECULATION.
HOW CITIES RETAIN LOCAL CONTROL
THROUGH OBJECTIVE PLANNING
STANDARDS LIKE BUILDING HEIGHT
SETBACKS AND LOT COVERAGE.
YOU'VE SEEN A RIGOROUS ACADEMIC
ANALYSIS FROM UC BERKELEY WHICH
FOUND THAT THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE NEW OPPORTUNITIES FOR
DEVELOPMENT. ON AROUND ONE
HUNDRED AND TEN PART THOUSAND
PARCELS. THAT'S A GREAT
OUTCOME. BUT ONE THE ONLY
REPRESENTS ONE POINT 5% OF
SINGLE FAMILY PARCELS STATEWIDE
HARDLY THE ELIMINATION OF
SINGLE FAMILY ZONING. WHAT I
WOULD ASK YOU TO CONSIDER TODAY
IS NOT JUST WHAT THIS BILL
DOES. BUT WHY WE ARE DOING IT
WE DON'T BUILD HOUSING FOR
HOUSING SAKE WE DON'T BUILD
HOUSING TO MEET OUR READING THE
NUMBERS WERE DISSATISFIED
DEVELOPERS OR ADVOCATES OR EVEN
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. WE BUILD
HOUSING FOR MORE BASIC REASONS
FAMILY COMMUNITY AN
OPPORTUNITY. THE CHANCE TO GROW
YOUR NEST EGG THE CHANCE TO AGE
WITH DIGNITY IN YOUR HOME THE
CHANCE TO HAVE YOUR CHILDREN
AND GRAND CHILDREN GROW UP IN
THE SAME NEIGHBORHOOD. THAT YOU
DID THESE ARE THINGS THAT MAKE
A COMMUNITY A COMMUNITY. TO
THOSE WORRIED ABOUT THE
CHARACTER OF YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD.
THINK ABOUT THE NEIGHBORHOOD
YOU GREW UP IN THINK ABOUT WHAT
IT MEANT TO RIDE YOUR BIKE TO
YOUR FRIEND'S HOUSE. TO GO SEE
GRANDMA TO WALK TO SCHOOL WITH
YOUR CLASSMATES. THESE
EXPERIENCES ARE THE FOUNDATION
OF CIVIC IDENTITY AND WE ARE
DENYING AN ENTIRE GENERATION
ACCESS TO THEM WE DENIED THEM.
AT OUR PERIL DO YOU WONDER WHY
OUR POLITICS SO DIVISIVE WHY
ARE EMPATHY IS SO LOW. THERE IS
A REASON THEY SAY THAT CHARITY
STARTS AT THE HOME. BUT IT'S
PRETTY HARD TO FEEL TERRIBLE
WHEN YOU'RE PAYING OVER HALF
YOUR INCOME TO RENT. LIKE MORE
THAN ONE IN FIVE HOUSEHOLDS IN
CALIFORNIA. WE BUILD HOUSING
BECAUSE HOUSING GROSS
COMMUNITIES DID YOU KNOW THAT
READ READ THREE REDWOOD TREES.
AS MASSIVE AS THEY ARE HAVE
VERY SHALLOW ROOTS. DESPITE THE
FACT THE BIG ROAD TO BE
HUNDREDS OF YEARS HUNDREDS OF
FEET HIGH AND LIVE FOR
THOUSANDS OF YEARS. THE ROOT
SYSTEMS ONLY GO DOWN TEN OR
FIFTEEN FEET. THEIR STRENGTHS
AND THEIR LONGEVITY COMES NOT
FROM DEATH BUT BECAUSE THE
INTERTWINED THEIR ROOTS IN A
NETWORK WITH OF THE REDWOODS.
THE TREES LITERALLY HOLD EACH
OTHER UP WITH THIS STRATEGY OF
MUTUAL SUPPORT. THEY CAN
WITHSTAND FLOODS MASSIVE FIRES
DROUGHT WIND AND YES EVEN
EARTHQUAKES. AND IT'S NO
pCHALLENGES WE FACE IN OUR STATE
REQUIRE A SIMILAR SURVIVAL
STRATEGY. FAR FROM WEAKENING
OUR NEIGHBORHOODS THIS BILL
WILL MAKE THEM STRONGER MORE
RESILIENT MORE INCLUSIVE. THIS
CAN ONLY BE A GOOD THING FOR
CALIFORNIA AND FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
ENCOURAGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU MISS GRAYSON MS
CLARK SILVA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS MEMBERS I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE
ONCE AGAIN I STAND HERE WITH A
VERY VERY DIFFICULT CHALLENGE
AND SOMETIMES STEPPING AWAY
FROM MY COLLEAGUES EVEN IN MY
OWN COUNTY. THE TRUTH IS BEING
ON THE HOUSING COMMITTEE
WORKING ON HOMELESSNESS ARE ALL
INTERSECTIONS WE CANNOT ACHIEVE
WHAT WE WANT TO ACHIEVE WITH
THE HOMELESS CRISIS UNLESS WE
BUILD HOMES SIMPLY WE ARE
BUILDING HOMES AT A RATE THAT
IS SLOWER THAN ON OUR NINETEEN
FORTIES AND NINETEEN SIXTIES.
NOW I HAVE HEARD THE CONCERNS.
AND THE NARRATIVE IS OUT OF
CONTROL SIMPLY MEANS MEANING
GETTING EMAILS SAYING WHY ARE
YOU TRYING TO. RUIN OUR SINGLE
FAMILY NEIGHBORHOODS WHY DON'T
YOU CARE ABOUT DENSITY OUT OF
CONTROL THIS BILL WILL DO
NOTHING TO HELP WITH SOLVING
OUR HOMELESS CRISIS FRIENDS
THOSE ARE ALL UNTRUE THOSE ARE
ALL UNTRUE PLEASE READ THE BILL
LANGUAGE PLEASE LOOK AT THE
AMENDMENTS AND PLEASE THINK
ABOUT WHEN YOU ARE A PROPERTY
OWNER THAT COMES WITH HAVING
SOME ABILITIES TO MAKE CHOICES
ON YOUR OWN PROPERTY. MANY
TIMES WE HEARD WITH THE EIGHTY
USE OR GRANNY FLATS OF YOU WANT
TO CALL ON THAT AND THE LAST
HANDFUL OF YEARS THOSE WERE
GOING TO BE BUILT OUT OF
CONTROL WE'RE GONNA HAVE A RUN
ON EIGHTY USE I ASK EACH ONE OF
YOU LEGISLATORS TO CALL YOUR
CITIES FIND OUT HOW MANY
PERMITS HAVE BEEN PULLED. AND
HOW MANY HAVE BEEN BUILT JUST
ON THE AD USE YOU ARE GOING TO
FIND OUT THAT THERE ARE MORE
THAN HAVE BEEN BUILT BUT NOT
EVEN CLOSE TO DOUBLING. SO WHEN
WE LOOK AT THIS BILL WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE A RUN ON SINGLE
FAMILIES WITH TWELVE UNITS. AS
WAS STATED THERE'S A
COMBINATION OF A DO YOU AND
EVEN SPLITTING LOTS WITH A
TOTAL OF FOUR. IN ADDITION SOME
OF THE NEW AMENDMENTS PROTECT.
NOT ONLY OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
CONCERNS OR COASTAL CONCERNS
BUT ALSO FIRE AS WE SAID
HAZARDS. THEY COMPLY WITH LOCAL
DESIGN THIS BILL IS A STEP IS
ONLY PART OF THE PACKAGE WE
NEED WE HAVE OTHER BILLS NOT
ONE OF THEM AS HAS BEEN SAID
WILL SOLVE OUR CRISIS FOR NOT
ONLY HOMELESS DEATH BUT
HOMEWORK OWNERSHIP BUT ALL OF
THEM ARE TOOLS THAT GIVE THE
HOME OWNER THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LOOK AT THIS THERE'S NO MANDATE
HERE. THERE IS NO MANDATE THAT
A SINGLE FAMILY HOMEOWNER WOULD
NEED TO SPLIT THEIR LOT OR
BUILD. IT'S NOT OPPORTUNITY TO
STREAMLINE AND MOVE FORWARD
FINALLY. MANY OF US HERE ON
THIS FLOOR OUR HOMEOWNERS
SOMEWHERE IN OUR FAMILY THERE
WAS HOME PURCHASED MAYBE BY
YOUR GRANDPARENTS MAYBE BY YOUR
OWN PARENTS. AND BECAUSE OF
THAT HOMEOWNERSHIP YOU
INSTANTLY MOVED INTO A CLASS
THAT IS A SMALL CLASS AND THAT
IS THE CLASS OF OWNING A HOME.
BECAUSE YOU OWN A HOME YOU WERE
PACKING YOUR BAGS AND MOVING
FROM APARTMENT TO APARTMENT
NEIGHBORHOOD TO NEIGHBORHOOD
AND YOU WERE ABLE TO PUT DOWN
ROOTS. NOT ONLY OWNING YOUR
HOME MEETING THEIR NEIGHBORS
GROWING UP WITH CHILDREN ON
YOUR SAME PER BLOCK BECOMING
LIFELONG FRIENDS AND INVESTING
IN YOUR COMMUNITY THAT'S WHAT A
HOMEOWNER DOES AND MANY MANY OF
OUR CALIFORNIANS ARE BLOCKED
FROM THAT OPPORTUNITY. THEY
DON'T EVEN HAVE THAT AMERICAN
DREAM THAT CALIFORNIA DREAM
BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO ACCESS TO
HOMEOWNERSHIP BECAUSE OUR
PRICES ARE SKYROCKETING WE WANT
TO OPEN THAT DOOR LITERALLY A
DOOR THEN WE NEED TO BUILD AND
WE NEED TO MOVE FORWARD AND I
DO SUPPORT SB NINE. THANK YOU
MISS CLARK SILVA MISTER FLORA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE AND
FOR A LONG TIME THAT WE SPOKE
ON THE FLOOR ABOUT A BIGGER
COLLEAGUES IN SOME OF THE
BIGGER THE MORE. URBAN AREAS
THAT IF THEY DO NOT FIX THEIR
PROBLEMS THEY WILL BECOME OUR
PROBLEMS IN A MORE RURAL-
DISTRICTS THIS BILL. TAKES A
STEP TO ADDRESS THAT THIS BILL
IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION IS A PERFECT
ABSOLUTELY NOT. FOR YEARS WE
TALKED ABOUT SOME OF THE GROUPS
THAT DO EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO
STOP PROJECT TO STOP-
DEVELOPMENTS UNDER LEGISLATION
UNDER LAWSUITS UNDER SEQUEL.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THAT
BUILDERS ALSO ONE OTHER THING
THERE'S THIS WEIRD CONCEPT IN
ECONOMICS CALL SUPPLYING DEMAND
IT'S VERY INTERESTING WHEN YOU
CAN SELL A TWELVE HUNDRED
SQUARE FOOT HOUSE IN IN SAN
FRANCISCO FOR WHATEVER YOU CAN
COME TO MY DISTRICT. BYE HOUSE
FOR TOP DOLLAR WELL GUESS WHAT
YOU'VE DONE YOU DISPLAY
SOMEBODY IN MY COMMUNITY MY
COMMUNITY CAN NO LONGER AFFORD
TO LIVE THERE ANYMORE IT'S TIME
THAT WE ALLOW OUR URBAN AREAS
TO DO WITH THEY THINK THEY NEED
TO DO TO FIX THEIR PROBLEMS SO
FRIENDS I KNOW THIS BILL IS
CHALLENGING FOR SOME BUT FOR
THOSE OF US THAT REPRESENT
RURAL DISTRICTS I DO SUPPORT
THIS- THERE'S A REASON WHY RC
RC SUPPORTS THIS BILL AS WELL.
AND I ABSOLUTELY APPRECIATE ALL
YOUR SUPPORT AND APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR. THANK YOU MISS FLORA MR
LEE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THAN
YOU COLLEAGUES I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB NINE I JUST WANT
TO BRIEFLY I THANK MY
COLLEAGUES ACROSS THE AISLE
THAT WE ARE AGREEING ON
SOMETHING TODAY AND WE I DO
AGREE WE NEED TO BE FIXING
URBAN PROBLEMS TO MAKE SURE
DOESN'T SPRAWL OUT AND FOR ONE
VERY CLEAR REASON IS THIS IS.
FOR ALL THE CALIFORNIANS OF MY
AGE MY GENERATION OR EVEN
YOUNGER WE ARE GIVING UP THE
IDEA OF THE CALIFORNIA DREAM IT
IS MUCH MORE ATTAINABLE TO
ATTAIN A HOMEOWNERSHIP DREAM
PERHAPS IN RURAL AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA OR OTHER STATES
ENTIRELY AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE
SEEING DECLINING ENROLLMENTS
ESPECIALLY EVEN IN MY DISTRICT
WHERE WE'RE NOT HAVING KIDS
ANYMORE. WE ARE IN RUNNING OUT
OF YOUNG STUDENTS TO KEEP OUR
PIPELINE STRONG AND ONE DAY ONE
DAY WILL HELP WILL NOT HAPPEN
IS WE'LL DRIVE EVERYONE AWAY
THE TALENT THAT WE HAVE
CULTIVATED THAT WE HAVE GROWN
IN CALIFORNIA WILL MOVE AWAY TO
OTHER STATES AND THAT IS A
FORTY SOMETHING THAT IS ALWAYS
ON THE TOP OF MY TO MANY
PEOPLE. AND I THINK ABOUT SB
NINE IS BEING SOMETHING VERY
EMPOWERING TO A LOT OF FAMILIES
IN MY DISTRICT WHERE THERE ARE
FOUR GENERATIONS OF IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES LIVING UNDER ONE
SINGLE FAMILY HOUSE AND THAT IS
NOT A PRACTICAL NECESSITY. IS
NOT OUT OF COMFORT IT'S NOT
HELD OF THE DESIRE TO BE REALLY
CLOSE ON TOP OF EACH OTHER
ALTHOUGH I'M SOME I'M SURE MANY
FAMILIES LOVE EACH OTHER THAT
CLOSELY. IT IS NOT THAT DESIRE
THAT IS THE PRACTICAL REALITY
OF MANY OF MY CONSTITUENTS IN
THE WEALTHY SILICON VALLEY IN
THE BAY AREA WHERE PEOPLE ARE
MAKING IN THE SIX FIGURES BUT
STILL CANNOT ATTAIN ANY SORT OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP OR SPACE THEY
NEED TO LIVE IN I'M NOT SHY
ABOUT TELLING THIS THE FOLKS
THAT I STILL LIVE WITH MY
FAMILY. AT HOME IT'S THE ONLY
WAY TO PRACTICALLY LIVE IN OUR
AREA WHERE MOST PEOPLE WILL
NEVER BE ABLE TO DREAM OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP I WAS TALKING TO
A COLLEAGUE OF MY FROM ANOTHER
STATE OR TALK ABOUT THE CONCEPT
OF STARTER HOME AND NOT FORCED
I FORGOT. WHAT THAT CONCEPT
EVEN IS FOR MOST OF OUR
GENERATION A WE JUST ATTAIN
HOMEOWNERSHIP AT ALL I KNOW IN
PREVIOUS GENERATIONS THERE'S
IDEA OF LEVELING UP IN HOMES
HOMEOWNERSHIP AND WE DON'T EVEN
THINK ABOUT THAT ALL. B. EVERY
YEAR THAT WE DO NOT ACT ON THIS
HOUSING CRISIS AND OF COURSE SB
NINE IS NOT AVAILABLE AS WELL
AS KNOWLEDGE IT IS A STEP IN
THE DIRECTION WE NEED ME MORE
AND MORE GENERATIONS OF
CALIFORNIA WILL LOSE HOPE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND I DON'T WANT TO
SEE MORE OF OUR FAMILIES MOVE
AWAY MORE FAMILIES BEING PRICED
OUT. WHATEVER REGION THEY'RE
LEAVING CALIFORNIA. SO I
HOPEFULLY OR JR I VOTE ON THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MICHELINE. MEMBERS I'D TRY THIS
ONE MORE TIME. IF YOU WANT TO
PARTICIPATE DEBATE RAGING
MICROPHONES RIGHT NOW. MISTER
NAZARIAN YOUR RESIDENTS. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. COLLEAGUES
I MUST RISE IN OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL. I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE ALL THE EFFORT
THAT'S GONE INTO THIS I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO COME UP WITH
SOLUTIONS BUT THE REALITY IS
THAT WHEN. SEVENTY SIX POINT 2%
OF HOUSEHOLDS AGE FIFTY AND
OVER AND SEVENTY EIGHT POINT 7%
OF HOUSEHOLDS EACH SIXTY FIVE
AND OVER. HOMEOWNERS RELY ON
THAT SINGLE FAMILY PROPERTY
THAT THEY ARE LIVING IN AS
THEIR PRIMARY INVESTMENT. WE'RE
GOING TO BE DEVASTATING THAT
INVESTMENT. I'M JUST BASING
THIS ON NUMBERS I'M BASING IT
ON WHERE THINGS ARE GOING TO BE
HEADED WE'VE SEEN THINGS LIKE
THIS BEFORE THERE'S GONNA BE A
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE AND IT'S
GOING TO BE DEVASTATING TO THE
VERY PEOPLE WHO WE NEED TO
PROTECT BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
INCOME COMING IN. IT MIGHT WORK
FOR THE FIRST FIVE TEN YEARS.
IT MIGHT ALLOW SOME OF THEM TO
BE ABLE TO SELL OUT AND MOVE IT
MOVE AWAY BUT IT'S GOING TO BE
DEVASTATING FOR ANYBODY ELSE
THAT'S IN THAT AGE RANGE.
THAT'S GONNA NEED TO HOLD ON TO
THE HOUSE BECAUSE THEY DON'T
KNOW WHAT ELSE TO DO AFTER THEY
SELL THE HOUSE. PLEASE THINK
ABOUT THIS CONSEQUENCE WE'RE
ALREADY SEEING. THE GREAT AGING
TSUNAMI COME COME TO COME TO
FRUITION BEFORE OUR EYES. IN
THE LAST TWO YEARS THE AGE
RANGE OF OUR ELDERLY
CALIFORNIANS SIXTY PLUS HAS
ALREADY INCREASED BY ALMOST 3%
SO FROM 11% TO FOURTEEN. AND IN
THE NEXT TEN TO FIFTEEN YEARS
IT'S GONNA GO UP 225% WE'RE
GOING TO BE DEVASTATING THIS
VERY TRUNCHEON OF INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE RELYING ON THEIR HOMES
TO BE THEIR NEST EGGS. AND WE
TALK SOMEONE BROUGHT UP
GENERATIONAL WEALTH COLLEAGUES
I'M AN IMMIGRANT. WHO'S BOUGHT
HIS HOUSE I AM THAT GENERATION
WHO'S TRYING TO DEVELOP THE
GENERATIONAL WEALTH AFTER WE
LOST EVERYTHING IN A WAR FORTY
YEARS AGO WHEN WE IMMIGRATED TO
THE UNITED STATES I UNDERSTAND
WITH GENERATIONAL WEALTH AND
ITS LOSS MEANS AND I'M TRYING
TO BUILD IT RIGHT NOW FOR MY
KIDS THIS ISN'T GOING TO HELP
THIS WORKS COUNTER TO THAT.
SHORT TERM IT'LL WORK LONG TERM
IT'LL BE DEVASTATING. WE TALK
ABOUT DISTRICTS THAT ARE LARGE
ENOUGH TO ABSORB THIS MIGHT THE
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT I HAVE THE
HONOR OF REPRESENTING DISTRICT
FORTY SIX. IN COMPARISON TO MY
GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA FOR EXAMPLE EITHER
OF MY TWO GOOD COLLEAGUES FROM
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WHETHER
DISTRICT ONE OR WHETHER
DISTRICT TWO. IS A FING A PINKY
SIZE FINGERNAIL COMPARED TO
WHAT THOSE DISTRICTS ARE
BECAUSE WE ARE DENSE. WHICH
MEANS THAT THE DENSITY IS GONNA
BE MISHANDLED WHEN THE SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES ARE SUBDIVIDED.
IT'S ONE THING TO BUILD UP IT'S
ANOTHER THING TO CONTINUE THE
SPRAWL IN DISTRICTS LIKE MINE.
SO I UNDERSTAND THE PRESSURES I
UNDERSTAND THE DAY THIS VOTE IS
COMING ON ALSO. IT'S WRITTEN
WE'RE GONNA LEAVE THESE JOBS AT
SOME POINT WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK AND LIVE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES I INTERNET I INTEND
TO GROW OLD IN MY COMMUNITY AND
I DON'T WANT TO SEE THAT
COMMUNITY GO DOWN HILL BECAUSE
IT WILL IN TWENTY YEARS WHEN WE
HAVEN'T DEALT WITH THE PLANNING
OF CONSEQUENCES OF BILLS LIKE
THIS WE HAVEN'T DEALT WITH THE
UTILITY WE HAVEN'T DEALT DEALT
WITH THE TRANSPORTATION WE
HAVEN'T DEALT WITH PARKING WE
HAVEN'T DEALT WITH A LOT OF THE
NEEDS THAT GO INTO
COMPLEMENTING WHAT INCREASED
HOUSING MEANS. WE'RE GOING TO
BE DEVASTATING THOSE
COMMUNITIES THIRTY SECONDS
BUSINESS AREA THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
US TO VOTE NO AGAINST THIS BILL.
MISTER JONES SAWYER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER BOB TODAY I'M IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE AND QUITE
FRANKLY I WAS ALL OVER THE MAP
OF THE REGIONALLY FOR S. B.
NINE WHEN I START ASKING
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE BILL I WENT
TO NOT VOTING AND THEN WHEN I
START ASKING MORE QUESTIONS.
ABOUT THE BILL. ALSO ANGERED I
WAS AT A NO BUT AFTER TALKING
WITH THE AUTHOR FINALLY
LISTENED TO MY CONCERNS TO
FINALLY LISTEN TO PEOPLE OF
COLOR'S CONCERNS AND FINALLY
LISTEN TO MY DISTRICT CONCERNS
AND ADDED AMENDMENTS THAT
ADDRESSED THOSE CONCERNS I
BECAME AND I AND THOSE CONCERNS
WERE GENTRIFICATION DENSITY AND
WHEN I CALL PRICES SEGREGATION
ANY AUTHORED GREED WITH ME THAT
HOUSING BILLS AND SUBSEQUENT
LOSS THEY DO NOT ACKNOWLEDGE
ALL WORSE AVOID THE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL SEGREGATION
GENTRIFICATION AND WEALTH
STAGNATION THAT. THAT WILL
PERPETUATE KEEPING PEOPLE OF
COLOR DOWN BECAUSE THIS HOUSING
IS THE PRINCIPLE GAP BETWEEN
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE CONSIDERED
DISADVANTAGED AND POOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE WEALTHY AND SHE'S
AGREED TO WORK WITH ME AS WE
COME UP WITH OUR OWN PLAN. FOR
HOW WE DEAL WITH THOSE THREE
THINGS BECAUSE IN MY DISTRICT
WHERE MOST OF THE LAND BECAUSE
OF THE HOUSING DROP WE HAD THAT
CRISIS MOSTLY LAND IS OWNED BY
CORPORATIONS AND SO
GENTRIFICATION IS REAL SOUTH LA
BEING WHITE AGAIN IS VERY REAL.
DENSITY YOU CAN'T PUT MORE
DANCE YOU CAN'T YOU CAN'T SEE
MORE DENSER AREA THAN MINE AND
SHE AGREED WITH ME WE NEED TO
LOOK AT THAT IN A WAY THAT. ALL
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY NOT HAVE
THE FINANCIAL CAPACITY TO MOVE
INTO OTHER AREAS WOULD HAVE
MORE ROOM THAT YOU DON'T END UP
IN THE SAME AREA AND THEN WHEN
I CALL PRICE SEGREGATION.
THAT'S A GREAT WAY FOR KEEPING
PEOPLE OF COLOR OUT OF CERTAIN
AREAS BY NOT SAYING YOU CAN'T
MOVE HERE BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
AFFORD TO COME HERE AND THEN
YOU KEEP ALL OF US TOGETHER IN
ONE PLACE AFTER PLACE. I'VE
LOOKED AT AND I'VE TALKED TO
THE AUTHOR ABOUT HER BILL AND
HOW WE CAN ADD ON TOP OF THAT
SO WE CAN ADDRESS MY CONCERNS
LIKE PUBLIC HOUSING WHICH IT
BECOME TO GHETTOS OF OUR
COMMUNITY RATIOS STILL WE HAVE
RACIAL ZONING IN SOME AREAS
THAT WE NEED TO GET RID OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP WHICH IS KEPT
POOR BLACK AND BROWN
INDIVIDUALS IN A PLACE WHERE
THEY CAN NEVER ACHIEVE THE
AMERICAN DREAM WHITE FLIGHT YES
WHITE FLIGHT LEAVING AREAS SO
THAT IT GOES DOWN IN VALUE
BECAUSE OR THEY TELL PEOPLE
DON'T MOVE TO THIS AREA BECAUSE
AN AFRICAN AMERICAN LATINO WILL
MOVE INTO THAT AREA SUPPRESS
INCOMES KEEPING PEOPLE ON
EDUCATED AND POOR IN ONE AREA
OF LIKE HOUSING PROJECTS IS A
PROBLEM THAT WE NEED TO SOLVE
RACIAL COVENANTS LOCAL TACTICS
BANKS THAT RED LINE INSURANCE
COMPANIES THE RED LINE ALL OF
THAT WE NEED TO TAKE IN
CONSIDERATION WHEN WE LOOK AT
HOUSING THE REASON I'M UP ON
THIS BILL IMBODEN YES. IT'S
BECAUSE OF THE THREE YEAR
RESIDENCY AND THAT LOCAL
CONTROL AGENCIES NOT ONLY LOOK
AT ENVIRONMENTAL BUT THEY LOOK
AT THE ADVERSE IMPACTS AND I
HOPE THAT THEY USE ALL OF THESE
NOTES THAT I JUST MENTIONED IN
THEIR EVALUATION ON WHETHER OR
NOT THEY MOVE FORWARD I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR. FOR EVEN
CONSIDERING IT BUT MOST
IMPORTANT I WANT TO COMMEND THE
AUTHOR FOR PUTTING THOSE IN
THIS BILL COULDN'T WE CAN BUILD
ON THAT ESPECIALLY WHEN I BRING
FOLKS TOGETHER THAT HOPEFULLY
NEXT YEAR WE CAN BRING OUR OWN
PEOPLE OF COLOR HOUSING ACT SO
WE CAN ADDRESS ALL THOSE ISSUES
ON TOP OF WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
DO WHEN WE PASSED SB NINE THANK
YOU THANK MISTER JONES SAWYER
THIS CARILLO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
WASN'T SURE IF I WAS GONNA
SHARE BUT I JUST LIKE TO ECHO
THE SENTIMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SOUTH LA ON GENTRIFICATION
MY COMMUNITY ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
FIFTY ONE HAS MOSTLY FOR A LONG
TIME NOW- AND AGAIN MY
COLLEAGUE MENTIONED WHITE
FLIGHT FROM THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES THAT FLED TO THE
OUTSKIRTS OF INTO THE VALLEY
AND OTHER PLACES AROUND THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES LEAVING THE
URBAN CORE- IT MOSTLY FOR
WORKING CLASS PEOPLE. OF MY
COMMUNITY HAS FOR A LONG TIME
BEEN A HISTORICALLY LATINO
IMMIGRANT WORKING CLASS
COMMUNITY WE ARE SEEN
INCREDIBLE GENTRIFICATION WE
HAD AT SOME POINT YOU TO FULL
CRAFTSMAN HOMES ALONGSIDE
SEVERAL DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES
THAT HAD IN THE PAST DUE TO
CITY ORDINANCE IN THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES BEEN CONVERTED A
TWO STORY CRAFTSMAN HOME INTO A
FOUR UNIT. APARTMENT- PLACE TO
LIVE WHERE IMMIGRANT WORKING
CLASS FAMILIES LIVED. THE
GENTRIFICATION IN MY COMMUNITY
THAT I'VE SEEN IS THAT THOSE
FOR YOU AND IT CRESSMAN HOME
THAT HAD ALREADY BEEN CONVERTED
INTO A FOR APARTMENT COMPLEX.
ARE BEING REVERSED BACK INTO
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES DISPLACING.
THE IMMIGRANT WORKING CLASS
FAMILY THAT LIVE THERE. SO WE
WENT FROM SINGLE FAMILY
RESIDENCE EAST TO A FOUR UNIT
RESIDENTS. NOW BACK TO A ONE
UNIT RESIDENTS. DISPLACING
COMMUNITIES AND INCREASING.
FAMILY THAT ARE LEAVING LIVING
PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK AND TO
LIVING IN THEIR CARS ALONG FIVE
PARKS IN MY COMMUNITY. NOT
KNOWING WHERE THEIR KIDS ARE
GOING TO GO TO SCHOOL WE HAVE A
HUGE PROBLEM WE CONTINUE TO
TALK ABOUT THE NEED OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE LACK OF
HOUSING THE INCREASE OF OVER
HOMELESSNESS AND ON HEALTH OF
RESIDENTS IN OUR COMMUNITY.
SOME OF IT VARIES FROM CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS TO RECENT
DISPLACEMENT OF FAMILIES WE
NEED TO ACT WE CANNOT CONTINUE
TO SIMPLY SAY WE NEED TO SOLVE
THE PROBLEM AND THEN BE UNABLE
TO MOVE FORWARD I AM
DISAPPOINTED. IN MY OWN CITY
AND THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES FOR
PASSING A RESOLUTION AGAINST IT
AT THE LAST MOMENT JUST LAST
WEEK AND I WANT TO APPLAUD ONE
OF MY OWN COUNCIL MEMBERS.
FORMER SENATOR GIL VIDEO WHO
STOOD STRONG IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE KNOWING. THAT IT IN OUR
COMMUNITY IT IS OUR COMMUNITY
THAT CONTINUES TO BUILD. WE
HAVE THE MOST DENSITY A HUGE
ISSUE WITH PARKING. A HUGE
ISSUE OF DISPLACEMENT WITH
FAMILIES WE CONTINUE TO BUILD
IN THE PROBLEM CONTINUES TO
GROW. SB NINE IS A MODEST
SOLUTION. THATAT THE END OF
THE DAY ALLOWS FOR LOCAL
CONTROL. IT HAS AS MR. MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SOUTH LA MENTION
PROVISIONS THAT THE AUTHOR HAS
PUT IN PLACE TO ENSURE THAT WE
COULD DO THIS IN AN EQUITABLE
WAY. THE MISINFORMATION THE
MISCOMMUNICATION THE LIVES THAT
WERE SEEN ON SOCIAL MEDIA FROM
PEOPLE THAT SAY YES WE WANT TO
BUILD JUST DON'T BUILD HERE.
BILL BUILT OVER THERE. ENOUGH
WE DON'T HAVE TIME TO CONTINUE
THE RHETORIC OF MISINFORMATION
SO I STRONGLY URGE MY
COLLEAGUES TO VOTE YES. ON SB
NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MEMBERS MYSTERY THIS YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
IN AND COLLEAGUES IN IT I WANT
TO AND ANA PERSONAL NOTE YOU
WANT TO ADD THAT CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING CRISIS IN TOUCH AROUND
FAMILY AS IT DOES I'M SURE FOR
MANY OF YOU MY MOM IS AN
IMMIGRANT SHE SINGLE PARENT SHE
REYES MY BROTHER AND I HELP MY
GRANDPARENTS HE JUST RETIRED
FROM TEACHING KINDERGARTEN AT A
LOCAL PUBLIC SCHOOL WHERE SHE
SHE WORK FOR THIRTY NINE YEARS
HE NEVER OWNED A HOME AND
THAT'S DESPITE WINNING BEING A
TEACHER OF THE YEAR MULTIPLE
TIMES A TEACHING OVER A
THOUSAND STUDENTS OVER HER LONG
CAREER SHE WAS NEVER EVER ABLE
TO FOR OWN HOME HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. SHE'S WELL WANTS TO
GROW OLD IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THIS GREAT STATE.
AND I FOLDER SHOULD HAVE TO
WORRY. BECAUSE HE HAS MEAN MY
BROTHER BUT FAR TOO MANY
FAMILIES IN OUR STATE ARE
HURTING THEY WORRY EVERY DAY
ABOUT WHETHER THEY'RE GONNA
HAVE A ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD
TONIGHT WHERE THEY GONNA HAVE A
ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD TOMORROW.
THEY MAKE TRADE OFFS WITH THEIR
HEALTH YOU GO HUNGRY FOOD
INSECURE. THEY PASSED UP GOING
TO COLLEGE AND THEY EVEN LEAVE
OUR STATE. FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN OUR HISTORY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. THE GOLDEN STATE IS
SHRINKING. COLLEAGUES WE HAVE
THE POWER TO ACT AND TO IMPROVE
THE LIVES OF OUR FELLOW
CALIFORNIANS AND POOR YOU TO
PLEASE GIVE THIS BILL A CHANCE
LET'S KEEP THE DOOR OPPORTUNITY
OPEN FOR ALL SB NINE THEY STEP
FORWARD IT'S A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND WITH THAT
MISTER SPEAKER RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU MISS
REAVIS AND WITH THAT CLICK
LIBERAL. MEMBERS THAT ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OF A RESERVE A.
CLARK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF ICE
FORTY FOUR NO SIXTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO A VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER WISH
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SEEING AND HEARING.
NINE. MEMBERS WE HAVE
RESOLUTIONS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR WHICH WE WILL BE
SEEKING CO AUTHORS THE CLERK IS
GOING TO OPEN THE ROLE ON THE
RESOLUTIONS ON CONSENT SO WE
MAY ADD AS CO AUTHORS CLERK
WILL. READ.
THE CARBURETOR
ASSEMBLY CURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VOEPEL RELATIVE TO ALL BE OPEN
EPIDEMIC ASSUMING CURRENT
RESOLUTION FORTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH
BOTH OF TO WOMEN'S SMALL
BUSINESS MONTH THE SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION NINETY
THREE BY SOME WE WERE BUT CHOI
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
CHILDHOOD CANCER AWARENESS
MONTH AS IN THE CURRENT
RESOLUTION NINETY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
RELATIVE TO THE PROGRAM OF ALL
INCLUSIVE CARE FOR THE ELDERLY
ASSEMBLY CURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
HUNDRED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO RELATIVE TO CHILD
SUPPORT AWARENESS MONTH. THIS
IMMIGRANT RESOLUTION WHILE TO
BUY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA AND
OTHERS RELATIVES CALIFORNIA
SEEK AMERICAN AWARENESS AND
APPRECIATION MONTH ASSEMBLY
CURRENT RESOLUTION ONE OF THREE
BY SOME MEMBER KALRA AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA HINDU
AMERICAN AWARENESS AND
APPRECIATION MONTH HOUSE
RESOLUTION FIFTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SAY ARTS- AND OTHERS
WILL TO CALIFORNIA DRIVING
PREVENTION MONTH HOUSE
RESOLUTION FIFTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE RELATIVE
TO PUBLIC HEALTH HOUSE
RESOLUTION SIXTY FIVE BY SOME
THE RIVER KILEY. BOTH OF THE
SARCOMA AWARENESS HOUSE WAS
LUCIEN SIXTY TWO BY SOME
REMEMBER KILL WEBER RELATIVE TO
READ BERMAN WE ESPECIALLY SINCE
SIXTY FOUR BY SOME REMEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN RELATIVE TO FIVE
ONE I DISEASE AWARENESS WEEK
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY FOUR BY CENTER ARCHULETA
RELATIVE TO VETERANS SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION THIRTY
SEVEN BY SEN ARCHULETA AND
RELATIVE TO LATINO VETERANS DAY
AND SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION EIGHTEEN BY SENATOR
CORTESE. RELATIVE TO
COMPASSIONATE CALIFORNIA
AVERAGE WELL ABOVE THE ROLE FOR
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTIONS
FOR CORPORAL HOW AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTIONS THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
WELL. CLOSE ROLE- SIXTY EIGHT
CO AUTHORS ADDED. THE CLERK
WILL NOW OPEN THE ROLE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
PAL RELATIVE TO OR GO TO BED
EPIDEMIC OUR CLUB IN THE ROLE.
ZERO THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE ABOUT. CLARK WELL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SEVENTY TWO
NO ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED AND THE CLERK WILL READ
THE REMAINING ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FORTY
FOUR I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NINETY THREE I SEVENTY TWO NO
ZERO ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION NINETY NINE I
SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO SO WE
CAN CURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
HUNDRED I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO
IMMIGRANT RESOLUTION ONE TWO I
SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE OF
THREE I SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
HOUSE RESOLUTION FIFTY. I
SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO HOUSE WIN
SOLUTION FIFTY SIX I SEVENTY
TWO KNOWS ZERO HOUSE WIN
SOLUTION SIXTY FIVE I. SEVENTY
TWO KNOWS ZERO ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION NINETY
FIVE I SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
CONSTITUTION SIXTY TWO I
SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
CONSTITUTION SIXTY FOUR I.
SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION THIRTY
FOUR I SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY SEVEN I SEVENTY TWO NO
ZERO SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY I
SEPARATE YOU KNOW ZERO SENATE
BILL THREE FIFTY TWO I SEVENTY
TWO KNOWS ZERO SENATE BILL FOUR
THIRTY FOUR I SEVENTY TWO NO
ZERO CYNICAL FOR NINETY SEVEN I
SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO SENATE
BILL FIVE OH NINE WITH URGENCY.
I SEVENTY TWO KNOWS HERE ON THE
URGENCY I SEVENTY TWO KNOWS
YOU'RE ON THE BILL SENATE BILL
FIVE FORTY ONE I SEVENTY TWO NO
ZERO SENATE BILL FIVE FORTY
NINE WITH URGENCY I SEVENTY TWO
KNOWS HERE ON THE URGENCY I
SEVENTY TWO KNOWS HERE ON THE
BILL SENATE BILL SIX FOURTEEN I
SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO SENATE BILL
SIX SIXTY ONE I SEVENTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO SENATE BILL SEVEN
FIFTY SEVEN I SEVENTY TWO NO
ZERO SENEGALESE NINETEEN I
SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO SEVEN
BILLION TWENTY SIX FIVE SEVEN
EIGHT ZERO ZERO SEVEN BILLION
TWENTY SEVEN I SEVENTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION EIGHTEEN. I SEVEN
ZERO ZERO AND SENATE JOINT
RESOLUTION. SIX FIVE SEVENTY
TWO NO ZERO. MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS MEMBERS HERE
COMMITTEE WILL BE MEETING UPON
OF SESSION IN ROOM FOR TWO- TO.
THE APPROPRIATIONS WILL BE
MEETING UPON IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
TO THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS FRIDAY AUGUST TWENTY
SEVENTH NO FLOOR SESSION A
CHECK IN SESSION MONDAY AUGUST
THIRTIETH THE FLOOR SESSION IS
AT ONE PM WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
COR CALL IS LIFTED WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
THE GERMANS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS ORTEGA
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS WE ARE ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR
AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE A GERMAN
TO MEMORY PLEASE EITHER TAKE
YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS FOR
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
MS RAMOS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TO ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF
TOSHIRO HENRY HANK KAMBALA ON
JULY TENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
CALIFORNIA AND THIS NATION LOST
A TRUE AMERICAN PATRIOT AN
AMERICAN HERO HOW CAN LIST OF
THE U. S. ARMY AFTER PEARL
HARBOR LATER HE WOULD JOIN THE
TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY SECOND
COMBAT ENGINEER COMPANY WHICH
HAS THE DISTINCTION OF BEING
THE ONLY UNIT IN THE U. S. ARMY
CONSISTING ENTIRELY OF JAPANESE
AMERICAN PERSONNEL TO INCLUDE
OFFICERS IN NINETEEN FORTY FOUR
HANKS UNIT WAS SENT TO ITALY
AFTER SUSTAINING A SHRAPNEL
WOUND IN ITALY AND BEING IN THE
HOSPITAL FOR SEVERAL MONTHS HI
COULD RETURN TO THE BATTLEFIELD
IN FRANCE AS PART OF AN EFFORT
TO RESCUE A BATTALION
SURROUNDED BY GERMAN FORCES IN
THEIR SUCCESS TO RESCUE THE
BATTALION HANKS UNIT WOULD LOSE
SEVERAL OF THEIR MEN FOR HIS
EFFORTS IN COMBAT HANK RECEIVED
A PURPLE HEART IT DISTINGUISHED
UNIT METAL JAPANESE AMERICAN
NISEI CONGRESSIONAL GOLD MEDAL
AND THE FRENCH LEGION OF HONOR
MEDAL IN TWENTY TWENTY WE
RECOGNIZE TANK AS A FORTY
SEVENTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
VETERAN OF THE YEAR AND HE WAS
LATER HONORED ON HIS ONE
HUNDREDTH BIRTHDAY HANK WAS A
TRUE EMBODIMENT OF SACRIFICE
AND SERVICE AND IS SURVIVED BY
HIS DAUGHTER SHARON AND HIS
BROTHER HIS SON BRIAN. I ASK
THAT THIS HOUSE ADJOURNED IN
HIS MEMORY. THANK YOU MS REYES
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY AND HONOR OF THE LATE
RICHARD TRUMKA HE PASSED AWAY
ON AUGUST FIFTH. TRUMP HAS
SPENT HIS ENTIRE CAREER
STANDING UP FOR WORKERS HE WAS
THE YOUNGEST LEADER THE UNITED
MINE WORKERS OF AMERICA AND
SERVED A DECADE AS THE
SECRETARY TREASURER OF THE
AFL-CIO BEFORE BECOMING ITS
PRESIDENT HE NEVER FORGOT HIS
ROOTS. WORKING AS A COAL MINER
IN WESTERN PENNSYLVANIA HE
WITNESSED AND EXPERIENCED
UNSAFE WORKING CONDITIONS TRUMP
I SAW THE FACES OF THE MEN WHO
HAD WORKED BY HIS SIDE AND HAD
DIED IN THE MINES UNTIL THE END
OF HIS LIFE HE LED ONE OF THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT STRIKES IN
AMERICAN HISTORY. AGAINST THE
PITTSTON COAL COMPANY WHICH IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE AND
NINETEEN NINETY. AT STAKE WAS
THE HEALTHCARE NEARLY TWO
THOUSAND RETIREES WIDOWS AND
MINERS ARE DISABILITIES. AND HE
WENT TO JAIL DURING THE STRIKE
AS PRESIDENT OF THE AFL-CIO HE
WASN'T INSISTENT VOICE IN THE
EARS ARE PRESIDENTS OF BOTH
PARTIES DEMANDING ECONOMIC
POLICY THAT BENEFITED WORKING
PEOPLE FULL EMPLOYMENT RISING
WAGES ECONOMIC SECURITY AND
MOST OF ALL BARGAINING POWER HE
HAS BEEN CRUCIAL IN PUSHING FOR
THE PASSAGE OF THE PROACTIVE
THE FEDERAL EVEL. ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT PIECES OF LABOR
LEGISLATION AND DECADES HE WAS
A DEVOTED FATHER HUSBAND AND
GRANDFATHER IT WAS A GREAT
HONOR TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO MEET MR TRUMP A WITH THE
SPEAKER AND IN HIS PRESENCE.
YOU CAN FEEL HIS STRENGTH IN A
TERMINATION. WE CAN LEARN SO
MUCH FROM HIS LEGACY. ALIVE OF
FIGHTING FOR ALL WORKING PEOPLE
AND THEIR RIGHT TO HAVE THEIR
VOICES HEARD YOU MUST HONOR HIS
LEGACY NOT JUST BY WORDS BUT
THROUGH ACTIONS THAT SEEKS TO
LIFT UP THE VOICE OF THE
WORKER. THANK YOU. DAVIS KALRA
MS GONZALEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I ALSO
RISE- TO TURN IN THE MEMORY OF
THE LATE- RICHARD TRUMKA. I HAD
THE GREAT HONOR OF WORKING WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP UP FOR MANY
YEARS AT THE AFL-CIO WHEN I WAS
HEAD OF THE LABOR COUNCIL IN
SAN DIEGO AND THERE ARE FEW
THINGS THAT STICK IN MY MIND
I'LL NEVER FORGET SEPTEMBER
SIXTEENTH TWO THOUSAND NINE THE
DAY HE WAS ELECTED PRESIDENT.
WE WERE IN PITTSBURGH AND HIS.
THEME SONG IF YOU WILL WHEN HE
WAS RUNNING FOR THE PRESIDENCY
OF THE AFL CIO WAS I WON'T BACK
DOWN THE TOM PETTY SONG AND
IT'S SO CAPTURED HIS APPROACH
TO- ENSURING THAT WORKERS HAD A
VOICE ON THE JOB HE NEVER
BACKED DOWN AND I THINK
SOMETIMES I USED TO JOKE- THAT
HE WAS ALWAYS AT THE GATES OF
HELL IN HIS JOB AND HE NEVER
BACK DOWN HE WAS ALWAYS LOOKING
FOR YOUNG LEADERS- ACTUALLY
STARTED AT THE AFL-CIO YOUNG
LEADERS PROGRAM TO TRY TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE OF US WHO
GREW UP IN WORKING CLASS
COMMUNITIES AND MAYBE LIKE HIM
WENT AWAY TO LAW SCHOOL STILL
CAME BACK INTO THE HARD WORK OF
ORGANIZING AND LEADING IN THE
LABOR MOVEMENT NOT FORGETTING
WHERE WE CAME FROM. AND HE GAVE
US THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE THE
LEADERS THE NEW LEADERS HE
POINTED ME THE AFL-CIO BOARD-
WHICH I WAS INCREDIBLE GRATEFUL
I GOT TO SEE HIM UP CLOSE IN
INACTION EVEN STANDING HIS
GROUND IN THE WHITE HOUSE TO
THEN PRESIDENT OBAMA WHEN.
HEARD IT DIDN'T MATTER HOW
IMPORTANT SOMEBODY MAY HAVE
BEEN OR OR HOW THEY LOOK TO WAS
NEVER DETERRED WHEN IT CAME TO
FIGHTING FOR WORKERS I FEEL-
EXTREMELY BLESSED TO HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO SEE HIM UP CLOSE
FIGHTING FOR SO LONG ANDTHAT THE LABOR MOVEMENT NEEDED
YOUNG PEOPLE IN A VITAL
INFORMATION IN IT AND THAT THEY
NEEDED TO BE UNAPOLOGETIC IN
STAND UP NO MATTER WHAT AND NOT
BACK DOWN THAT WAS PRESIDENT
RICHARD TRUMKA. AND I HOPE YOU
WILL JOIN ME IN A TURNING IN
HIS MEMORY. THANK YOU MISS
GONZALEZFORMER MAYOR OF THOUSAND OAKS
ELECTED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR AND SERVING TILL NINETEEN
NINETY LARRY WAS THE FIRST
BLACK COUNCIL MEMBER AND FIRST
MAYOR INVENTOR COUNTY DURING
HIS SIXTEEN YEARS OF PUBLIC
SERVICE LARRY WAS KNOWN FOR HIS
INTELLECT AND ABILITY TO BRING
PEOPLE TO THE TABLE HELPING
GUIDE THE CITY AS IT GREW FROM
FORTY THOUSAND PEOPLE TO OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND. ONE OF HIS
BEST KNOWN PROJECTS IS A CIVIL
ARTS PLAZA WHERE HE SUPPORTED A
VISION OF ARTS WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITY LARRY ALSO WORK FOR
REPRESENTATIVE BRAD SHERMAN AND
IN MANAGERIAL AND EXECUTIVE
POSITIONS AT LOCKHEED MARTIN.
LITTON INDUSTRIES AND NORTHRUP
GRUMMOND GRAMMOND REDEVELOP THE
BUSINESS ACKERMAN THAT HE
BROUGHT TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT. A
DEVOTED FAMILY MAN LARRY IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE OF SIXTY
SIX YEARS BETTY. AND HIS THREE
CHILDREN KIMBERLY CYNTHIA AND
LARRY JUNIOR HE WILL BE MISSED
BY COUNTLESS OTHER FRIENDS AND
FAMILY INCLUDING MYSELF WE WILL
REMEMBER HIM NOT ONLY FOR HIS
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THOUSAND OAKS
AND VENTURA COUNTY BUT FOR HIS
DEDICATION AND KINDNESS I ASK
THAT WE ADJOURNMENTS MEMORY
THANK YOU MISTER WHEN AND MS
BURKE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN MEMORY THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS- TODAY I
RISE TO REQUEST THAT WE RETURN
IN THE MEMORY OF MALCOLM
BENNETT. MY HEART IS HEAVY DUE
TO THE RECENT PASSING OF A GOOD
FRIEND OF THE STATE LEGISLATURE
IN PARTICULAR A FRIEND OF THIS
HOUSE MR MALCOLM BENNETT
MALCOLM BENNETT WAS BORN IN
SELMA ALABAMA ON JUNE TWENTY
NINTH AND MOVED TO CALIFORNIA
IN THE EARLY FIFTIES. MISTER
BENNETT WAS ACTIVE IN THE LOS
ANGELES REALISTIC COMMUNITY
WHERE HE SERVED AS PRESIDENT OF
VARIOUS REAL ESTATE BOARDS AND
SERVED TWO TERMS AS PRESIDENT
OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD
OF REAL ESTATE MISTER BENNETT
ALSO SIR FOR TO SUPERVISORS MY
MOM YUVAN SUPERVISORY UPON
BURKE AND MARK RIDLEY THOMAS ON
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY TAX
APPEALS BOARD. AND SUIT
CERVETERI TERMS AS PRESIDENT OF
THAT BOARD. IN ADDITION TO
BEING A STRONG FAIR HOUSING
ADVOCATE MR BENNETT WAS THE
PRESIDENT AND FOUNDER OF THE
MINORITY APARTMENT. OWNERS
ASSOCIATION WHERE HE PROVIDED A
STRONG VOICE FOR MINORITY
TENANTS AND PROPERTY OWNERS
ALIKE IN SACRAMENTO MISTER
BENNETT ALSO FAITHFULLY SERVED
ON A NUMBER OF PROFESSIONAL
BOARDS INCLUDING REGIONAL VICE
PRESIDENT FOR THE NATIONAL
PURPOSES YUSHIN BOARD OF
DIRECTORS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS AND THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS. MEMBER OF THE MULLIN
WOULD OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE AND
SOUTH LOS ANGELES COLLEGE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE. HIS
COMMUNITYINVOLVEMENT ALSO
INCLUDE TWO TERMS ON THE BOARD
OF DIRECTORS OF THE SOUTH
CENTRAL REGIONAL LOS ANGELES
CENTER FOR THE DISABLED MISTER
BENNETT HAS RECEIVED SEND OUT
NUMEROUS RECKON RECKON
INSTITUTIONS FOR HIS WORK AND
COMMITMENT TO THE COMMUNITY
SOME OF HIS HONORS INCLUDE
CONGRESSIONAL HALL OF RECORDS
FOR OUTSTANDING COMMUNITY
SERVICE IN NINETEEN NINETY FOUR
BY CONGRESSMAN JULIAN DIXON.
ANY APARTMENT INDUSTRY LEADER
OF THE YEAR AWARD IN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN FROM THE
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION.
CALIFORNIA SOUTHERN CITIES. THE
LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY WILL MISS
MISTER MALCOLM BENNETT DEARLY
AS SOON AS HIS PROFESSIONALISM
HIS EMPATHY TOWARDS OTHERS. AND
MOST OF ALL HIS FRIENDSHIP I
REQUEST THE INTERNET HAS
MEMBERS THANK YOU AS PER M. IS
RIVAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. I RISE TODAY TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF MY DL
HANDING OUT ALL METAL. BODY I
WAS BORN ON MARCH EIGHTEENTH
NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR IN
MICHOACAN MEXICO. SHE
IMMIGRATED TO THE UNITED STATES
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE AT
THE AGE OF NINETEEN WITH HER
HUSBAND AND THREE YOUNG
DAUGHTERS. SHE REUNITED WITH
HER MOTHER'S SISTERS AND
BROTHERS AND MADE HER HOME IN
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY. AS A
RESIDENT OF SILMAR. MAHDIA WAS
A ROMANTIC AND LOVE NATURE THE
ARTS PAINTING MAKING CRAFTS
MUSIC AND MOST OF ALL TRAVELING
SHE LOVES SPENDING TIME WITH
HER FAMILY AND HER BELOVED DOG
BADLY BACK MARIA WAS A DEVOUT
CATHOLIC AND A PILLAR OF THE
COMMUNITY IN ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
THIRTY NINE SHE LOVED
VOLUNTEERING AT HER LOCAL
PARISH AND HELP MANY OF MY
CONSTITUENTS AND MOST OF ALL
SHE ENJOYED MAKING NEW FRIENDS
AT RETREATS AND GATHERINGS
MAHDIA BRAVELY FOUGHT BREAST
CANCER FOR MANY YEARS GOING IN
AND OUT OF REMISSION THREE
TIMES. SHE PASSED AWAY
SURROUNDED BY HER LOVED ONES ON
JULY TWENTY EIGHTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. MAHDIA SURVIVED BY
HER MOTHER ANTONIA HER THREE
DAUGHTERS AS THEY LACK TONI AND
MONICA. HER SEVEN GRANDCHILDREN
VIVIANA DANIEL CHRISTIAN
SAMANTHA JULIAN LOUISE AND
FATHIMA AND HER BELOVED GREAT
GRAND CHILD LOU LOU I ASKED
THAT WE ADJOURN IN MARIA'S
MEMORY THANK YOU THANK YOU MS
RIVAS THANK YOU MEMBERS ALL
OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE
PASSED RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL
BE CONTINUED SAYING AND HEARING
A FOR THE BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MR LEVINE MOVES AND MISS RIVAS
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY AUGUST
THIRTIETH AT ONE PM. WE ARE
ADJOURNED.